jackal focus in a battle is
easy how do you keep focus in a long war
i.e long-term goals
well that
that that can definitely be true it can
be pretty easy to focus on the battle
that's right in front of your face
and when you're doing that sometimes you
can
lose track of the the long-term goal
but i want to have that
that long-term goal so
embedded in my mind that i never lose
sight of it
ever and those little tasks and projects
and
short-term goals that you tackle they
need to lead toward
that strategic victory
winning the long war
and we get very caught up in
instant gratification we want results
now
we want the shortcut to the winner's
podium
and sometimes you know when we don't get
that
short-term glory that we want we
lose track of those long-term goals
and you you look up in in six weeks
or in six months or in six years
and you've made no progress
none you never moved
you might even be further from your goal
than you were
why why
did you let that happen
it's because you lost sight of that
long-term goal
and at some point after you lose sight
of that goal
and years have gone by you think to
yourself
maybe i can't
maybe i can't do it
and so you give up and you let it
fade
and you settle
you settle for mediocrity you settle for
average you settle for
oh well
but no no
don't do that embed that long-term goal
in your mind
burn it into your soul
think about it and write about it and
talk about it and hang it up on your
wall
but most important do something about it
do something about it every day every
day
do something that moves you toward that
goal
that keeps the goal alive and in sight
and
in focus
however however small
or insignificant that step might seem
take it
do it do that little piece
make it happen
because that goal
isn't going to achieve itself
it's all on
you